the new york post it says it's a senior
teen vogue staffer who opposed alexi
mccammon's
hiring as editor-in-chief over troubling
tweets as a teen
had herself repeatedly dropped the
n-word in online posts according to a
report
christine davitt a senior social media
manager
at the connie nest mag had earlier this
month made public a letter by staff
complaining about mccammon's hiring
in light of her past racist and
homophobic tweets so this was
we talked about this last week alexa
mccammond was
hired to be she's a very left-wing
black woman who was hired to be the
editor-in-chief hired from axios to be
editor chief of teen vogue
and there was this cancel campaign that
started within
the teen vogue ranks because of some
tweets that alexie mccammon had sent out
10 years ago when she was 17
which were really pretty innocuous at
the end of the day especially because it
was a 17 year old
sending them but she got cancelled for
that and now we know that
one of the the people at teen vogue this
um
uh christine davitt who was involved in
cancelling
uh alexi mccammond had herself when she
was a teenager also sent out
uh racist tweets so davitt wrote
uh on her twitter after
mccammon was fired she wrote so proud of
my teen vogue colleagues the work
continues
then just hours after mckimmon announced
a resignation saying that her tweets as
a 17 year old college student have
overshadowed her work since then
david wrote on twitter uh quote
exhales the deepest sigh i've ever
sighed so she was relieved
finally we got rid of this racist yet
david who calls herself a queer
fat philippines femme in brooklyn
um that's how i describe myself too
actually
incidentally uh no she says she's a
queer fat
philip pinks okay so we've already i
guess i should have figured we were
gonna do this we're doing la tinx
set a latino or latina now we're doing a
set of filipino we're saying philip
pinks
but turns out she had she still had up
on her twitter old posts of her own in
which she repeatedly dropped the n-word
she at least twice the post reports
referred to a friend who appears to be
white
as a quote n-word with the with the a at
the end not the er
but still in 2009 in the next year also
she used the n-word in a joke tweet
um and those have since been
resurfaced i don't know now she's gonna
have to lose her job too
you know the dominoes fall
you get held to your own standard
now in reality again
it would be it's completely crazy
objectively speaking it is completely
crazy that we would be holding anyone
accountable
for tweets they sent out in 2009
you know when they were teenagers it's a
completely crazy thing to do
but you how can we not hold you to your
own standard you were
just insisting that someone else get
fired for the same damn thing so of
course we have to apply it to you
we have no choice i don't i don't like
it really personally
what choice do we have though this is
your standard this is what you this is
the world
you wanted to live in and so now we're
going to allow you to live in it
it's what you wanted you said
now uh and it keeps going meanwhile a
woman named ellery smith
apparently a comedy writer um tweeted
after the shooting in atlanta she
tweeted this
quote remember when someone had their
snl offer revoked after using an
anti-asian slur
and so many people thought it was an
overreaction hateful language
begets violence hateful jokes beget
violence they minimize and they
dehumanize and they allow for the
normalization of terror so
um and this uh yeah she's apparently
some sort of comedian
and this is in reference to shane gillis
who was fired from snl a couple years
ago for some jokes that he had told in
the past about asians
and now ellery smith is bringing that
back up and saying
and actually partially blaming shane
gillis as if he hadn't been canceled
enough he lost his job
but partially blaming him for the
shooting in in atlanta
yes because i'm sure that the shooter
who even though he
he never indicated he had any anti-asian
sentiments at all
uh elder smith has decided not only did
he have anti-asian sentiments
but he was motivated partially by shane
gillis's jokes about asians
well because she said that some
enterprising person on twitter went
through ellery ellery smith's old tweets
and found
found at least one from 2013 where she
jokes about how thai food
has has uh has cats in it you know the
old joke about
asian food having cats and dogs she made
a joke like that in 2013.
that came up and this is how she
responded to the guy who who
brought that old tweet up she said i
posted a tasteless racist tweet when i
was 17.
it was disgusting and normalized the
exact kind of violence that i meant
luckily i had been willing and slash
able to grow in the past eight years so
i look a lot more like the girl on the
left on the left referring to her most
recent tweet
than i do on the right
well there it is again now
and and once more normal circumstances
if we're speaking objectively who cares
about the tweet she sent
in 2013 when i guess she was a teenager
even if she wasn't a teenager
a joke about how asians have cats and
dogs so what
by the way that's a stereotype that
isn't it didn't
it wasn't we don't pull it out of thin
air that is an actual thing that has
happened and does happen in some asian
countries
so you make a joke about it who cares
even if she made the joke yesterday who
cares
that doesn't normalize violence in no if
you make a joke about asian cuisine
in no way shape or form are you
encouraging or even
implying or insinuating that anyone
should commit any violence at all
against anybody
obviously
but she herself was trying to pin a
harmless joke on someone else made it
supposedly an anti-asian joke and she
that's that's her standard
even though it's crazy we have no choice
but to
apply it to her but of course she gets
to say
oh i've grown since then i'm a different
i'm changed
so that's the thing you notice about the
cancel culture mob they get to grow
right they get to change and grow and
become different people
no one else is allowed to they're
allowed to
no then see we can't we can't go along
with that
what we have now is this is a it's
become a war of attrition
this is mutually assured destruction
if this is the game you want to play
it's going to be turned back on you
right like this is a nuclear cold war um
that's what this is you don't want to
get
you don't want to lose your job over
dumb stuff that you said 10 years ago
then don't try to do it to other people
i think that's pretty reasonable in the
end well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content